so let's talk about Aspen ol versus
Sergey pavlovich there's a thing going
on right now especially lately these big
fights fall out and they replace that
fighter with even bigger name or a
bigger fight or at least complimentary
to it it's a massive fight either way so
it's all good on the fight side we love
this as a fighter though it kind of
sucks because you're getting the biggest
opportunity of your life and you're on a
two-e notice it's not ideal for those
guys also as a consumer you just see the
names like oh this can be so dope you're
right but the problem is is you're
getting a water down version that being
said Tom Absol Sergey pavlovich two
weeks take my money I'll watch him fight
every Saturday if I could I think Tom
Aspen is the best heavyweight the UFC
has to offer I think he proves that in
Mass Square Garden and I think he wins
I'm taking Tom Absol under five rounds
he gets a finish with a TKO or a
submission he's too quick he's too witty
his fight IQ is too high to get caught
in exchange with Sergey I think he
fishes under five